the flu season is straining resources at
hospitals nationwide the Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention reports
the flu is widespread in 46 different
states some hospitals are setting up
emergency tens to handle the high volume
of patients others are dealing with a
shortage of IV bags after Hurricane
Maria cut power to manufacturing plants
in Puerto Rico
Michelle Miller is at Massachusetts
General Hospital in Boston where staff
is trying to cope with the shortage in
what some think is a very unusual way
Michelle good morning good morning well
if you have ever been inside of a
hospital naívi bag is a familiar sight
to you it holds the life-saving fluids
and medicines delivered through IV while
supplies of this very necessary Hospital
staple are dwindling and doctors and
nurses are getting creative raising to
find other ways to care for their
patients
all right next gonna give you that
Gatorade now in the intensive care unit
at Massachusetts General Hospital nurse
Hannah Owens pike uses Gatorade to
combat dehydration takes a while doesn't
it it now takes her four times as long
to administer treatment that would
normally be delivered intravenously
hospital staffers are forced to conserve
supplies as the nurse we look at our
patients and see if there's any possible
way to give a fluid electrolyte and
medication in any way other than in an
IV fluid the shortage is widespread
3,000 miles away near San Diego then
Boyer's wife zhenya Trejo is undergoing
chemotherapy for a brain tumor these
nurses work so hard it worries me that
they don't have everything they could
possibly need at their disposal Boyer
says they became aware of the shortage
after Christmas during one of zenia's
treatments suddenly this nurse who looks
after several patients has to stand
there for half an hour
slowly pumping in these pre meds you
sort of think this is brutal this guy
should be probably helping other
patients when hurricane maria slammed
into puerto rico last september it
forced the temporary shutdown of Baxters
manufacturing plants baxter makes more
than 43 percent of the united states his
IV solutions market
the company told CBS News they produce
tens of millions of sterile IV solutions
every year
Owen spike traveled to Puerto Rico to
help with Maria's relief effort but is
dumbfounded by the storms impact back
home not until this happened do we
realize how many things were actually
being produced there and how it is
significantly affecting the whole
country's medical system Puerto Rico is
a hub for medical pharmaceuticals the
island produces 40 billion dollars for
the US a year this is a nationwide
problem which is part of what makes it
so hard is that we can't borrow from any
other Hospital dr. Paul biddinger is
chief of emergency preparedness in Mass
General he worries about the low supply
of IV bags during the peak flu season if
we had a very severe flu season start to
develop in the next weeks and months
that could push us over the edge
now Baxter pharmaceuticals tells CBS
News that production is back online
since the restoration Puerto Rico's
power grid the FDA believes that things
will get better in coming weeks but
consider this Jeff they are dealing with
a three month long backlog hard to
believe Michelle thank you very much